[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube hey you
want to hear something funny I actually
recorded this video and then I didn't
plug the mic in so there was no audio
I'd like doing things twice over for no
apparent reason yeah so you guys already
know what these videos we kind of like
to keep it blacks very casual very lazy
fair I think that means hands off that's
not the words I'm looking for you guys
are asking a lot of questions in the
comments section below and I want to
search hug kill because now we get to
come room not take time but one of the
questions that I have been asked a lot
was to tell like certain stories and
specifically a story that came up
because I talked a little bit about this
when I did a carpool confessions with
the homegirl Ellen Kim was about the
first time I had sex I gotta say friends
you came to the right person because
Davis cell was a no-bullshit flyzone and
I'm gonna tell you the truth when it
comes to this stuff oh and by the way
the question I'm really asking about
what it was like it's kind of like the
story about how it led to the first time
that I had sex and kind of what was
going on through my mind now growing up
for me a lot of the friends that I grew
up with had sex at a very very early age
I was considered a late bloomer and I
had sex for the first time when I was 18
first time everybody was banging each
other left and right apparently at the
age of 13 to 14 trying to figure out why
hair was popping out all over the places
people over here just just sticking it
to people just and I was always so weird
for me you know because like these dudes
that I would kick it would they would
sit around they would talk about y'all I
was with this girl right and we was
hooking up right I don't know what they
were talking about I was over here you
know trying to sound like I'm
knowledgeable about that [ __ ] yeah you
know something you have to grab it and
ankles you don't say I've been clapping
them together not tied up like a bow tie
and I put it on my neck so I'd say extra
formal [ __ ] and you want to know a
funny thing - I have a friend right now
till this day I will always remember
this because we used to kick it in his
garage and all the dudes would be
talking about having girls and whatever
like hooking up I wouldn't and even this
dude's dad was making fun of me
this guy was Filipino and this
[ __ ] said to me did you forget -
I'm what you don't like booze booze
booze booze
first of all little one don't don't ever
say booze booze to me second of all
don't say puss-puss and do this
statutory pervert fishface what the hell
the most uncomfortable situation even
somebody's dad was rose
me man before I even had sex I had like
this crazy pressure to lose my virginity
and I was trying to get rid of my
virginity like it was a cancerous mold
you know hi and I don't know why I feel
so pressured to have sex I mean clearly
was because everybody was getting on my
case about it but you know on top of
that too I felt like you know maybe I
wasn't like a real dude if I didn't lose
it you know what I mean which is dumb
because that's such an important part of
your life and you should do it at your
own pace and when you're ready but all I
had was boosts plus on the break so when
that time came with my very first
girlfriend for us to actually like hook
up like dude I I was doing a research
man not like I wouldn't read a book in
school but when I came to a vagina I was
studying that [ __ ] like it was nuclear
physics there's like a little speed bag
over the vagina was a quick topic little
rice it was so much pressure but by the
time that I had the opportunity to hook
up with it and when it did happen
everything that I learned from above out
the [ __ ] window I was like trying to
find the vagina with my penis doesn't
ooh does it go here and I didn't know
that the vagina is not really like face
upwards so I was like tried it like you
know I'm saying it was like but I will
say this when it finally went in was it
everything that I expected
absolutely [ __ ] yes people were not
entered her heavenly cavernous hole
D'Angelo came on and I gotta tell you
something - the first time I had sex I
was absolutely terrible I didn't know
what was going on man it was I just kept
you know just bang it was no finesse and
the weird thing was - like I felt so
nervous about it because every time
these bunch of dudes would get together
and they would talk about their sexual
conquests they would talk about their
dick like it was the most amazing thing
ever you know what I mean and it wasn't
the case - it just guys are so [ __ ]
dumb sometimes man we're like so used to
trying to put our best foot forward and
pretend like we're so amazing at things
because we feel like we have to and if
we don't we feel like we're not men and
that's just a stupid concept but and it
took for a young lady to tell me that my
dick games suck for me to review what I
was doing and learn how to better
communicate when it came to having sex
let me just give you an example
all right there's this dude that I know
he is not my friend he is somebody
that's within the group that I like and
he's just that big guy in there that I
just everytime I meet him he talks about
some kind of bull
to story where a haber I was in the bar
right and I was like throwing hay or B
you know I brought this girl riding I
gave her there if she was like you know
like nobody even asked about how his day
was or how his night he just voluntarily
just gives us this information about how
amazing is cool story bro but long story
short anyways one time I was over at his
place and there was his girl that left
and then after she left he was talking
about yo I just hooked up with his girl
man is she [ __ ] man I gotta tell you
dude I was give it to her heart
so whatever do but guess what a couple
weeks after that it turns out that girl
that left is actually a friend of a
friend of mine and I met her at a
birthday dinner so check this [ __ ] out
so it was kind of awkward when I saw her
just because I talked to her a little
bit when I met her at that apartment a
while ago but I was hoping that she
didn't remember me so I was just being a
little weird about it later on as the
night went on she did remember who I was
and I was like yeah oh so how did it
turn out with you in and she said it
didn't work out well because his dick
game was terrible yes my friends she
legit said his dick game was terrible
this is what I'm talking about man
people who put up this like stupid sense
of bravado about their sexuality number
one you're [ __ ] annoying and number
two it clearly shows that you're
insecure about yourself if I could go
back in time I'm not saying that I
wouldn't have had sex with my very first
girlfriend but I wish I wouldn't have
felt that pressure to write and I would
have been able to communicate better
with her with what she liked and what I
liked and our relationship probably
would have been a lot better
I can't wait to my sex drive guys man my
mom would be so [ __ ] clear I'll solve
nuclear physics I'll cure cancer [ __ ]
folks there's like a speed bag about the
vagina are you supposed to do what let
me tell you something kids if you're
trying to wait for marriage I suggest
that you do don't ever say something
like you know what I'm just going to do
it once and I'm never gonna have sex
again until I get married now it doesn't
work that way you don't want you with a
girl right and you're getting it from
behind
wanna get their right position and you
just kind of [ __ ] eating it like gee
did and a girl like you know what they
feel right right